good morning good afternoon
and welcome everyone to today's live
broadcast
lifting the veil on innovations and
product launches
2020. i'm alexis krauss of labyrinths
and i'll be our moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by brooker daltonix for
more information about our sponsor
please visit their website at
brooker.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click on the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr marcus kosroeva
director senior vice president r d
regulatory and scientific affairs broker
deltonics
microbiology and diagnostics for a
complete biography on our presenter
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr costrella you may now begin your
presentation
welcome ladies and gentlemen to the
presentation
about the innovations of broker in the
area of microbiology and diagnostics
most of you may know me i'm marcus
crosby seva i'm heading the innovations
part
of microbiology and diagnostics of
broker
and i'm happy to present you now
what are our new developments our
development
and research results in the year 2020
normally i present this in seminars
around the eckmate and asm
this year unfortunately we were not able
to do that so we
decided for this online format and i
hope it will be informative and you will
enjoy it
my presentation will have four parts
in the first part i will guide you to
through some
developments and some state-of-the-art
in microorganism identification using
the multi-biotyper
and developments we did regarding this
the second one will be about rapid
antibiotics
build testing using multibiotyper
then i will guide you through some new
developments in hospital hygiene and
classification using the irbi
typer and last but not least i will give
you a short preview about developments
in molecular diagnostics
multibiotiper series 1 is our
youngest member of the multibiotyper
family that we are presenting this year
essentially it's something like the
little brother of moldy by type of
series
and the specialty in this is it has only
the positive iron mode
to cover all the routine workflows you
have in your laboratory
in other cases it's just very similar to
multiple type of series
as you know it having a smart beam laser
with 200 hertz
for fast measurement having a high
capacity vacuum system
for rapid accessibility for measurement
the electronics is new
and environmentally friendly we in
addition
improved usability by improving the
outer design for better disinfection
and what's also a nice feature is that
the system starters can be checked by an
led strip
in addition to development on the
hardware we also expanded
the capabilities of our android
individual diagnostic software
for the european union certification ce
we expanded the ivd software by adding a
software module for subtyping
so what does subtyping mean subterming
in this case means
you can identify markers as an example
for resistance detection of bacteria
or you can sub differentiate species of
subspecies
which are closely related and cannot be
differentiated by the standard workflow
now as first applications we have
introduced the differentiation of cfia
positive
bacterial dysfunctionalists from those
that are cfi negative
the difference is that the positive
bacterial fragilities are carrying a
karbapinomis
a gene which makes it highly resistant
against carbapenum antibiotics
the second functionality is the
detection
of blood kpc expressed glyphsyl of
pneumoniae and issues
which also having a strong resistance
against carbocation antibiotics
as a third we introduce the first
species differentiation which cannot be
achieved
in a simple way in this case the
differentiation between
mycobacterium chimera from mycobacterium
intracellular an important
differentiation as
in the recent years mycobacterium time
mary has been detected
from intercooler systems infecting
people
so here you can see how the output of
subject detection
looks like in a further column now in
addition to
the identification the log score and the
commands the subtype is given as
see if i positive or negative kpc
positive if applicable
or typed as mycobacterium chimera or
intracellular as it applies
a very important part of moldy bicop of
course
are databases the main databases the
large ruo and ibce labeled databases
have been extended significantly i would
say
more than one 000 new reference entries
have been added
representing 21 genera and 278 new
species
with this we're further clean uh
extending the clinical
coverage of diversity but also of
species
here are some species given that have
been added in addition
i might find on additional strains also
for
staphylococcus argentius and
psychostaphylococcus schweitzeri which
now can be validly
and well differentiated from
staphylococcus aureus
in addition we added also not only
clinical but environmental species
and another important feature is we
improved
and renewed the taxonomy
so taxonomy is permanently changed and
we are doing our best to being up to
date with our databases each year
i would like to give you some examples
for the improvements that we have
achieved
and i have to say this is very important
for us that you help us
with this and that is a very good
collaboration with our users and
customers
that we get input from you and that we
get also recommendations from you
how to update how to extend and how to
improve our database
one of these hints came in the area of
the bacter genus there were several
publications
that said akinudobacter genus is not
good enough covered
by databases it's more diverse there are
more species and it could be improved
we we listened to that we saw that in
publications and we can
also discuss this with our users
and finally we received a big number of
academic strains
explicitly from alexander nemech from
bragg
we evaluated these strains could
incorporate 169 of them
into our library now having a huge
extension
overall with 22 new species
to an enormous coverage and you see how
we can extend our database
in the interaction with you
a very special database is the one for
the multibiotapa ca or clinical
application
this database and the system for it are
only for sale in the united states and
puerto rico
as the regulations of the fda are
different
from those regulations where the ibtce
labeling can be applied
we have now also improved significantly
the database for the multi bi-type
ca system we have added 59 new species
in groups and also
we added a renaming and improvement of
naming and
up-to-date naming for a lot of species
and species groups
also here i want to give you some
examples
very important is the genus of elizabeth
kingia
this is something where we can see the
historical development in taxonomy and
also the influence it has
on clinical diagnostics initially
elizabeth kingia behold bricola and
menigo septica
have been defined in 2005.
just in 2011 a new species
elizabeth kingia anophelus has been
defined
and determined so later on
it appeared that this is the main
species and formerly
was just classified as one of the other
two species
we have investigated that thoroughly
added a number of strains
and cover now this species diversity and
species differentiation very well
and have them in the multiplicability
database inclusive
inclusive very thorough validation
also for accidental factor we added the
further species
which is now part of the aquinobacter
armani
complex this is formerly called
actinobacter
xornier which found was found at the end
to be the same like
akinidobacter luxury that has been
defined earlier
and also now is part of the complex and
can be nicely differentiated from the
other species
and at the last something special i
would like to point on
wolfartimona's this species
was the one that was the first that we
had on our t-shirt
in acme where we sometimes present a
t-shirt
somebody has found something really rare
with the moldy by typer
and we call it is the species of the
year
and say what have you identified today
so this was the first example detected
by a german customer
later on once you had in the database it
was detected again and again
especially by clinical laboratories
especially from blood cultures
so we collected these strains we even
found strains in our earlier clinical
studies in the united states for
modified type
ca in the pre-identification wrongly
identified as another species by other
systems
now we have collected enough of them to
add them to the multiply type saa
database
and do a thorough validation according
to the requirements of the fda
so this is not something esoteric it's
found again and again and it's of clear
clinical relevance
so you see how things are changing from
esoteric to clinical
relevant bacteria
maybe for most of you the biggest
surprise in our development today
is that we are moving towards automation
of sample preparation for the multibio
typer
here you see the soon coming multibyte
upper pathfinder
equipped with a feeder solution the
multibyte upper pathfinder
is dedicated to the automated
preparation
of colonies from bacteria and yeast from
an agar place
onto the moldy target including the
matrix
deposition the feeder option is for the
automated feeding of the pathfinder
from a hotel and the system has a nice
traceability and documentation
capabilities as i will show you
here the workflow of the system
pathfinder including the feeder
once you start a project and you run
of course the multiplate is placed into
the system
and all the reagents
after that after start the automated
scanning start of a pretrial dish
a barcode that is at the side of the
petri dish registration of the sample
the sample is automatically inserted in
the dish
in the system so this part is the
connection between
feeder and pathfinder
then an optical scan of the plate is
done
a colony is selected thereby that's
what's happening is that the pathfinder
makes a recommendation for colony
and you can accept that or you can
select manually another one
after this selection
first on the target formic acid is
deposited
and after this test position of formic
acid
that's something special the transfer is
transferred the the colony is
transferred into
this droplet of formic acid after drying
of the sample
matrix is automatically deposited
after that has been done for all samples
the run is closed and finished
the sample can be introduced with the
target plate
into the multiply topper for analysis
so overall the system shows nice
features like
a lot of cleaning and sterilization
processes
it cleans the needles automatically
it also prevents crystallization of
matrix in the needles
and the wires are sterilized that are
transferring
after the transfer by heat
the reagents are dosed by separate
needle
formic acid and multimatrix it's
contactless we don't use
piper tips colony and selection
as that can be automated but also can be
manually changed
and there is a special function for
detection if bacteria are slimy
and would cause problem by transfer then
the process is interrupted
to prevent any contamination inside the
system
the full workflow is transparent and
traced
very well there are a lot of pictures
made and stored
from all process steps so later on for
troubleshooting it's
very easy to follow the whole process
barcodes are used for traceability
targets automatically recognized and
also the petri dish surface
the heating the drying limits are all
automated
so far about the identification using
the multiply typer and the sample
preparation for it the second part
i would like to guide you through our
developments according to
rapid antibiotic susceptibility testing
using the multiply typer
this is an overview about workflow we
call
mbt fast forward what does that mean
we have a workflow covering two aspects
one is the rapid
detection of antibiotic resistance or
susceptibility
using moldy tof namely the moldy typer
as the readout
this part works in 5.5 hours plus
preparation time
so same day results are available as a
second
we have an overnight incubation of the
same sample
to get a real mic determination at the
next day
we are using combined antibiotic plates
like here shown in the lower part on the
left side
the first two rows you see are for the
fast part
same day break point detection the
second part
forward is on the right side here where
you see many dilution points for more
antibiotics
the whole process is near to complete in
development
i will guide you through the results of
our developments
we have recording consumables you have a
software module
and also a tool for incubation and
removal of supernatant
here a quick view on again on the
workflow
you see the bacterial sample coming from
an agar plate or from the pellet of the
sepsi typer
so from the blood culture isolation
is put as an inoculum in an antibiotic
plate
and now a part of this trade is used for
the fast workflow
this means at the same day you get a
result by
inoculating from there a multi-biotype a
target plate
incubating that in a special chamber
when the bacteria are resistant they
will grow in the droplet on the target
and when they grow they will adhere to
the moldy target and later on you can
measure
a spectrum and identify identify the
susceptible bacteria will not grow
and there will be no measurement of a
spectrum with the bacterium
and there will be no identification so
the same day result for urgency asterisk
on the other hand the same sample
inoculated
in a classical pro microdilution plate
and this is incubated overnight and then
the next state
there is a real mic detection
that a confirmation or correction of the
mpd fast result and there are more
antibiotics which are determined
now this system will come with
some consumables that are supporting the
whole workflow
one of those is of course the antibiotic
blade here our broken merlin branch
is supplying us with these according
plates and antibiotics
they have a lot of experience in this
and are known for high quality broth
micro gluten
dilution assays
it will contain nine antibiotics for the
rapid ast
same day result with breakpoints
according to ucas
it will have 16 antibiotics overall for
next day
real mic determining
the second consumable is a special
matrix that we supply
that the matrix concern obtaining an
internal standard
which ensures validity of analysis
because if no bacterium is grown and no
bacterial spectrum
is measured nevertheless the standard
has to be measured
if the standard is there then the
analysis has worked
and the bacteria are not grown if the
standard is not detectable something
else was wrong
for the removal of the supernatant after
the
intubation we have some pets which are
removing the supernatant together with
the stem in a very rapid and very simple
way
and at last we have some special broth
for the growth
in a multitop compatible way
this is a view on the incubation chamber
which we are calling mvt fast shuttle
there's a multifunctional hardware
dedicated to empty fast
but also potentially for other
applications
it has a touchpad function it's very
dense it's very controlled
easy to use and also just small fitting
on each workbench
an according stand for the removal
of the culture supernatant after
incubation is also supplied to ctr on
the right
part and besides the application for mbt
fast
this tool also will be developed further
to enable a rapid drawing for the id
workflow i will show you later
but also for other essays like fast
essay to
confirm normal coccy and for
acceleration also and simplification
of our star blsas
also a part of software of course is
needed for the analysis for the
measurement and analysis
of according spectra to mptfast you see
a view on the gui here it's a software
module for multi-biper contrast
dedicated for this analysis the whole
workflow is software guided
measurement is done and started
automatically also the
sensible intermediate resistant
classification is done automatically
there is a plausible check and warnings
of inconsistencies
the system gives also a pdf report and
data can be
exported via comma separated values
as already mentioned this shuttle will
not be
only applicable for mbt fast
ast but also for other
workflows and the most simple workflow
for that is the acceleration and
standardization
of the drying procedure for
identification
we have observed in some laboratories
that in some
very humid summers as an example the
samples are drying slowly which also can
have a negative inference on the later
on measurement
using the mbt shuttle this all can be
accelerated and standardized
we have seen and measured acceleration
of the whole
workflow from starting the preparation
to the measurement
of up to 50 and the nice thing is
up to now 10 different species have been
thoroughly tested
the lox cost of the quality of
identification we get
is at least as good as in the normal
procedure using room temperature
maybe even somewhat better the influence
of
environmental conditions is clearly
diminished and the system will be
validated for msp96
polysteel target plates but also for
biotargets of course
further possible workflows for the
amputee fast shuttle
are the acceleration and simplification
of our
star bl workflows for detection of
carbopylases and for detection of
several spirinases
as you've seen here see here we also
think that we can reduce
time to the result by half approximately
and the further test is published by
afghani danovich
in just this year that's the
confirmation of bromococci by a
objective automated biosolubility test
using multitophms
very similar in the procedure to amputee
fast for ast
we developed this as a standardized
essay using these tools
and it can be used later on for same-day
results
for confirmation of bromocracy after
identification
with a modified type
so far about rapid asd using
multibiotyper
and the tools and consumables around
that
in the third part i would like to guide
you through our
improvements and novel developments for
hospital hygiene
subtyping classification of
microorganism using infrared
spectroscopy namely the iobi typer
you see the picture of the i buy type
that we introduced just recently
we are now already in the third version
of the software that we've developed
with a lot of feedback
from our users and own ideas
so coming from
the new interface
you can see here some improvements like
increased robustness of the system after
some experience in the field improved
usability
in the usage of the software
especially important the introduction of
a new workflow
in parallel to the classical hospital
hygiene workflow
that is the implementation of building
of classifiers
of machine learning to create
classifiers and apply classifiers i will
guide you through this later
we extended the wavelength that can be
analyzed
to the full range that is measured when
we started we restricted ourselves to
the carbohydrate range
which is most informative but there's
also information in other molecules and
we have expanded the system that can be
analyzed now
we also improved the visualization
namely by introduction of a nice
3d scatter plot
and also very important we included some
new connectivity
on one hand the multibite upper can be
connected to the irbi typer
as it should be as members of a family
so the species identification generated
by multiplier typer
can be transferred directly to the ir by
and in future these
capabilities of transfer will be
expanded on the other hand our byte
upper also can be connected to the
laboratory information system
and transfer data there
so at first from the application side i
would like to show you
some nice result of the now let's call
it classical
workflow of the mod of the infrared
bi-typer
for real-time epidemiology in hospital
hygiene
so this example comes from bologna from
university hospital there
a quite big university hospital and the
work was performed and i think that is
really remarkable
during the copied crisis in april when
as you know in april the hospitals were
full
especially university hospitals and a
lot of urgency was there and the people
were really under stress
so it was hard to do anything else than
kobe testing that time
nevertheless this hospital hygiene
observation was made
it started by an outbreak
of an aquinolobacter bombani that was
carbohydrate resistant only colistin
susceptible
in the ward of the universal hospital
and you see here the first
measurement so there was an index
patient patient
zero and after that eight fought more
samples have been taken in the first
week after this first patient
and they're all clustered closely and
i would not like to say nicely together
with the index patient
the negative control is clearly
unrelated and you see also it's totally
separated
the threshold that is applied here is as
we give it in our manual at 0.4
so normally now each day the sample
would have been measured but as this was
in the pandemic situation in very bad
conditions much worse than we have it
today and we all hope it will not come
back again
so in this case only once a week the
measurement was performed
which nevertheless was remarkable
because of the shortage
of personnel you see here now
the result after the second week so at
one hand
again eight new patients appeared so
it's spread over the world
and in addition other samples from
another hospital
another ward and another hospital you
see in the lower part given here in
violet
we are also separated from those but
also clustered
in that pointing already on there might
be another outbreak in another hospital
one feet week further again
more patients got this i cannot
money on the initial board as you see
all gray
so it's now 24 patients there and in
addition
on a further ward in the further
hospital the strain that caused the
second
outbreak see below this dark one
among the violet ones this one
clusters together with the violet
hospital it's called
so you could say well maybe that's
random
but actually what had happened is that
the patient
in this third hospital third ward came
from this lower hospital from the
hospital where the second outbreak
happened
and transported or hopefully not seeded
this
multi-resistant aquino aquifactor bomani
again in a new hospital on a new world
i think a very impressive example how
the iobi typo can be seen as a method to
observe and hopefully prevent and reduce
the spread of an outbreak at the
hospital wall
coming to some more features of the eye
by the three
here you see a 3d scatter plot in this
case after a linear discriminant
analysis
of zero groups of cell vanilla
salmonella is an area where we're
currently working hard on
it's very fruitful to work on this with
the ir bi-typer we get a very nice
separation
from the zero groups and that's also
depicted here you see here the different
colors
that are representing different zero
groups
different 0 groups of salmonella
and interestingly when we reduce the
number of different
zero groups and focus especially on this
o9 group
then you can see that inside
the o90 group salmonella trifi which is
highly pathogenic
can be well separated as a subclass
in the group this has been now confirmed
by a lot of strains and we're working
with our partners in bologna on that
also for our publication
so such results now enable us
to further develop it from
just observation by similarity to
classification
what i've shown you up to now was
unsupervised analysis
without information what is related to
what just looking at the similarity of
strengths and thereby
by similarity detecting something like
an outbreak
tracing such outbreaks creating also
contaminations in
farmer companies or in food industry
on the other hand if we know classes
that can be differentiated and we see
that such classes
can be separated like as an example the
zero groups of salmonella
we now can use machine learning
to calculate classifiers mathematical
biomarker
based classifiers that later on
can be used for classification or
subtyping or differentiating
so the workflow is from a training data
set
that is well defined of node samples
spectra are required
these are fed in the algorithm the
machine learning algorithm in
our case now an artificial network this
uses it to learn to learn how to
separate the different classes
and then creating a model so-called
model classification model
this classification model later on then
can be used
to classify unknown samples and the
output is as you see here then
similar to the multi-bi type with a
green and yellow and red quality with
the classification and detailed
information
so we have applied this as an example
in some approaches now as an example to
salmonella
but by the way also for bromococci
serotyping
and for the differentiation of
leguinella zero group one
from the other serotypes so here you see
an example for salmonella
differentiation of different zero groups
and the result of those 23 zero groups
were used in this case
a training set measured on a tsa
argon was used to create the
training set from this
with the neural network the classifier
could be
trained and created and then 166
independent isolates
were analyzed and these were done grown
from tsa
but in addition even a larger number of
strains was grown
on another argon on columbia blood agar
and also tested against this tsa derived
neural network and as you can see
with the tsa medium very good results
could be obtained there was no
misclassification in this test
but there were some not classified that
means red
but interestingly also somewhat worse
even from columbia blood argon normally
you always try to be as standardized as
possible
even from this more than 80 percent of
the samples were
correctly classified against the new
network created
based on strains grown on tsa only four
misclassifications happened
so you see there's quite some robustness
in this method
especially for salmonella in addition
also of course we looked at the
truthy problem so we created the subnet
a network that was just applied against
the o9 determined
strains and indeed we could see with
this
network the non-cliffy from trifi
someone that could be differentiated
this was done in collaboration
with simona ambretti from the university
hospital of bologna
but also with a reference center for
veterinary and food from
parma
collaboration with of our customers and
partners that are
experts in their field and that can
supply the
expertise about samples and of course
also the samples
so far about hospital hygiene i a
biotyper
at last but not least i would like to
give you a quick view in our molecular
diagnostic branch
we are also now in the fight against
kovite
namely in the diagnostics of saskof2
so as a series of developments for
respiratory essays
at first we have developed a real-time
pcr
assay that can be used to identify with
high sensitivity and high specificity
the sask of two virus it's called sask
of two plus
because it also can detect the endemic
human coronary viruses
that are not as highly pathogenic and as
you see here from the analytical and
clinical performance startup of this
cervd marked assay there's a very good
sensitivity analytically
but also sensitivity and specificity are
very good for
this essay and that has been also now
confirmed we have launched the system
in may and the feedback is very good for
it
we got get now to winter and we all know
and we see it already the winter will
get more
problematic again in addition
to flask of 2 rising probably
because we're all more inside and close
together
the flu might come back and also other
respiratory viruses so as an answer to
that
we are developing an assay that can
detect the sask of 2
virus again with two different genes
that are detected
which increases its robustness but also
it can detect influenza a
and influenza b separately
it is also made to detect rsv a and b
not differentiated but just as a warning
and all this is in a five color single
tube assay
currently we have this system as reo kit
and the ca labeling is in preparation
validation studies are running
and look very promising we intend to
launch the system for the detection of
this different virus during the next
week
and at last we are also in development
of a broader panel
of a real broad panel for viruses
bacteria
and fungi that can cause respiratory
infections the so-called
syndromic panel this we do
with our patented so-called liquid airy
technology
and thereby it's possible to have in
only two tube assay
17 different respiratory viruses
nine bacteria and one fungus
this all runs in two tubes and enables
such a very broad detection as
normally only possible with systems that
are used point of care
for few samples and thereby not in
higher throughput
this is in development and we are
intending to launch that in the
in the way of 2020
this is one of the essays that we are
developing
which are called so-called syndromic
panels that means detection not only
from
one class like virus or bacteria or
parasites or fungi
but just according to the syndrome
wherever it comes from
detect the pathogen further developments
in this area are as an example detection
of
pathogens that are causing
gastrointestinal infections
and another one the first one has been
already developed and is ibca labelled
and that is for
sexual transmitting diseases it's an
essay
and you see the analytical and
diagnostic
values of this sample from the ibdc
labeling here it's done to detect
seven different pathogens partially with
dual targets
it's a single tube assay also using the
liquid airy technology
and by that also enables a high
throughput rapid detection
of these pathogens in a simple workflow
this is just the start of development of
such assays
rapid assays in high throughput that can
be used to detect a lot of different
pathogens or also mutations in sample
so with this i want to conclude my
presentation
just pointing on other presentations
that will follow
other webinars there will be dedicated
webinars
explaining more in detail what we are
doing and what we are presenting
about molecular diagnostics about the
serious and related
developments about unknown
susceptibility testing with the model in
plates
about the irbi typer and also about
multibiotype
sepsi typer where an expert insight will
be given
i hope you enjoyed a little my talk and
i could give you some interesting
information
and by that i would conclude with my
presentation and of course i'm open for
any questions
thank you a lot for your patience
thank you dr croshueva for that
informative presentation
we'll now start the live q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
it will answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
which additional sample preparation or
tools
are needed to get mbt subtyping ivvd
results
it looks like we might be having a
little bit of technical difficulties
with
uh with dr costrova so we'll try to get
him back
on the phone
hello hi thank you sorry
we can't you yes yeah sorry obviously a
technical problem
so i got the question
okay i got the question
and i answered already but i will repeat
of course
actually it's just a bioinformatics
capability for the subtyping
so nothing is necessary from the sample
preparation it's just a method by
bioinformatics
by another complementary method to draw
out more information of the same spectra
that have been acquired for
identification
perfect thank you so much for that so
we'll move on to our next
question which is is it possible to
replace or at least
guide the selection of whole genome
sequencing usage by the ir biotyper
in outbreak studies in clinical hygiene
this in indeed it's also a very
interesting question and of course
over time we have to find out about the
positioning of the system
uh we don't think and intend to
substitute a ghost standard like whole
genome sequencing
but because of the high quality but
especially also rapidity
and low cost of the system we see it as
a
method to have a rapid answer to guide
and then
be confirmed by other methods like whole
genome sequencing
so i think it will be more substitute
for many analysis
and it will reduce the high cost high
effort analysis
to a minimum where it's really needed
wonderful thank you now dr questroy but
do you
do we have to buy media from brooker in
order to have the barcodes
i know bruca will not sell media we are
not
intending to go to this business there
you are free what you're selecting
okay so our next question is can the
envy
can the mbt shuttle be used for drying
all
including id related maldi targets
indeed this is one of the aims we have
it's not yet validated for our nvidia
diagnostics
but we have tested quite a number of
samples already
with very promising results and one of
the intentions is indeed as the lowest
effort
application to use it to accelerate and
also to standardize
the drying process before identification
now does this work with molds as well
well um that is not yet tested
we will have to have a look at that but
it might be
that the my cell is
not really suited for such a kind of
preparation
okay so it looks like this question
um looks like our next question has a
couple parts to it
so for the fluorotype sars kovi 2 plus
are you using gxtna extraction carriages
if yes what are you using for the
amplification
and the fluorocycler or something else
and is the fluorotype sars kovi 2 plus
an
amplification kit okay indeed a
a complex question there's a couple
parts to it
yes and they try to to explain that
in detail so it is an amplification kit
a pcr kit
which is validated indeed with a
genextract na kit in addition we do
bridging studies also to other
extraction protection methods
so it's not only restricted to the
cartridges for the naked but it's
validated based on that
then it was about the pcr
cycler that can be used indeed the
validation was of course done with the
fluorocycle xt
but it also runs on a couple of other
pcr machines and that you can find also
at the leaflet
the validation was done also that it can
be applied as a individual diagnostic on
that
um was there a further part of the
question which i missed
i think it's application it is a pc
arcade of course it's a kit for pci
amplification
a single tube for several targets
wonderful thank you so much i know that
i know there were a couple parts to that
question
so we'll move on to our next one
are the subtyping results also contained
in the
in the lms export or lims export excuse
me
um the multipatter subtyping yes indeed
that is also now
part of the the transport for the export
to the laboratory information system
wonderful now dr cosueva
our next question are the subtyping
results also contained in the
oh excuse me i just said that um well
our next question with the fast module
comes
comes the new ht platform do the non
htmbt software and its workflows
still run with this new fast workflow
uh okay i understand yes indeed
we are moving our our
data analysis for modify typer to the so
called ht or high throughput platform
and the mbt fast module will be
a part of that but it's not a problem
to have both systems so the compass
software as well as the hp software
software
on the same system and thereby having
all the capabilities that we are
offering on the same system
also the identification and subtyping is
performed and fast is performed
on the ht platform so there's
compatibility of both systems that they
can be
run in parallel as long as we don't have
all functionalities on the hd platform
wonderful so we do have time for a few
more questions and we want to thank our
audience for all these amazing questions
that are coming in today
um just a reminder all those questions
that we do not have time for today
and those that come in during the
on-demand period will be a
will be addressed by dr kosciuva with
the email address that you provided at
the time of registration
so our next question what is the
capability of connection planned
between mbt to irbt
yeah we did the first step now
by delivering the the species
information
to the ir by tupper so the species
identified by the multiply typer
is transferred but of course in future
we
intend to expand that and you just can
imagine all the information that we are
generating on the multibyte hyper site
which might be interesting as an example
a resistance profile that is stored in
in the multibiotyper server
or subtyping information all this of
course in future step by step
can be transferred and connected in a
last
step i nicely can imagine that also some
typing results
obtained by maldi which is not the same
but complementary to infrared typing
might also be combined and thereby a
kind of grid of different typing
technologies with high resolution can be
generated
so that's something over the next years
we will introduce step by step
now will the ir biotyper work on
mycobacteria
that's a good question uh hopefully but
i have to admit that we did not test
that yet
in principle it should work but it might
need some special
sample preparation for that
wonderful thank you so much so
this our next question how long does it
take
for the mbt fast give the ast result
you know the current technology takes
approximately 16 hours
yeah so the incubation time for
antibacterial
that's the first essay we're working on
is 5.5 hours
we are somewhat limited here by the
growth of the bacteria and the
expression of the resistance
including sample preparation it will be
approximately six hours
of sample preparation before and
measurement
which is for those blood cultures that
are positive in the morning the same day
result at least
but i have to mention of course that the
detailed result also will be
then available next day on the forward
part
of the plate by classical broth my group
dilution and then giving also
a to mic and also correcting if the
short result has shown some
inconsistencies
now will the ft sars
influenza assay also run on non-broker
pcr machines
yes it indeed we are validating
this also on other machines
there might be at least two further
cyclers where it's running on
um as this is a high complex
multiplex it has to be
adopted to machines that are capable for
the separation
but i said in addition to the flow cycle
xt at 2
at least two machines have been
identified they also of course will be
mentioned in the package insert
great thank you so much for that
clarification now is it possible to
replace or at least
guide the selection of whole genome
sequencing usage
by the ir biotyper in outbreak studies
in clinical hygiene
this is at the end the intention of
what we want with our biotyper
we think that whole genome sequencing or
other
high resolution high effort technologies
can be partially replaced and thereby
the throughput and speed can be in
hospital hygiene can be a
clearly increased wonderful
now about pathfinder can you compare the
result of systems with manual sample
preparation study
we don't have yet validation data for
that that we can publish
you have to understand that we will wait
until that has been finalized and then
we can ibdc label but from the first
results and the feedback of
testing sites that we got um
we can say that the results look like at
least as good
if not better as manual preparation
i think that especially in let's say in
hectic laboratories
with also maybe some new technicians
that that
uh are not as skilled uh and
the manual work will even be of lower
quality as a standardized system
like the pathfinder which at the end
each day works the same level
and that's a quite high level as we have
observed
now regarding the ir biotyper you've
already introduced
some classifiers which additional ones
can we expect in the near future
okay about the classifiers so we
currently
we are working on a number of
classifiers already
we have seen as a very simple example
that
the zero group one from legenella
bromophila
can be nicely separated from the other
zero groups which has some
meaning because of the higher
infectivity
we have already published and to work
more on
stereotyping for normal coxa and as i've
shown
also the zero group differentiation and
even some more differentiation in
salmonella
is something we're intending but there
might be also other examples
where it can be applied or we thought
about hemophilus capsular types as an
example
but that has to be shown at the end in
experiments and not everything will work
another possibility might be yet
not deeply investigated as an example
the differentiation of klebsiella
capsular types so we have some first
results about that and we also know from
publications that
klebsiella the capsular types seem to be
nicely separated
but that needs of course a lot of work
and what is limiting here sometimes
is the alternative technologies that are
available
to compare with ir by table because they
are very often
slow expensive and expert systems
but over time i see that we will create
a number of such applications and
classifiers and of course also users can
do that themselves
in the local situation and create their
own classifiers and apply that
wonderful now um dr chris weber we have
a time for a cup just a couple more
questions
maybe one or two so we'll move on to
our next one which is uh what is the
pathfinder throughput and timing
so the pathfinder throughput is
approximately
a full target plate in an hour that can
be prepared overall
so it's not the mainly the speed that
makes the pathfinder
but the precision the automation and the
very good documentation of the process
including photographs wonderful thank
you so much
for that so how does the user select the
colonies
and how does the pathfinder locate them
so the of course the simplest way to
to locate colonies is by eye but the
pathfinder
equipped with the feeder also uses a
machine learning algorithm
to identify colonies and these colonies
then are proposed
for picking but if the user thinks that
his either better or the machine
learning of course is not uh
always the optimal he also can change
that and select another colony
if that's necessary
now it looks like we have time for maybe
one more question
and this is a two-part question does the
machine learning of the new irbt
software is comparable
to the identification in the mbt and
can it point out that the newly examined
strain
is the same of an outbreak previously
analyzed
again a good question so i understood
the
first part um how the identification of
the ir by type if that would be applied
compares to the
multibiotyper and here i would say
generally the identification for
identification multiply topper
is the the better system because it's
uh very robust and it also does not
need any information about um
what kind of organism has been used uh
it's just uh
looking for a similarity match and very
few
influenced by any medium or temperature
so the
overall robustness i think is is just uh
hard to beat
on the other hand for some
differentiations where the multiply
tapper is not
suitable not every information is hidden
in the multi spectra
also some people would like to see that
in these cases
we might see that the a kind of sub
differentiation
identification is possible using forward
spectroscopy
and the second part could you repeat the
same part of the
question of course can i point out that
the newly examined strain
is the same of an outbreak previously
analyzed
oh yeah we're looking here at
probabilities and
at the end that's exactly the intention
and
if you remember the the slide that i've
shown about the
outbreak in bologna this is
exactly what was shown there that the
there was an outbreak and at one point
even
there was for the second outbreak a
transfer of strain
in the second hospital so this tracking
and tracing
is possible here um with some limits we
don't know how
long it is over time probably some
controls have been also measured
over time to see that the system still
works in the same range
but overall that is of course one of the
intentions of the system
[Music]
thank you again dr koshova for your
your presentation do you have any final
comments for our audience
well my final comment would be that we
will be happy
to answer any more detailed question
deeper question also by the specialists
of the projects
everything that is asked here should get
a thorough answer
and i also would like to point on the
upcoming webinars where my colleagues
specialists in their fields give
insights to
the areas where i just could point on
and give you a first overview
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
we would like to once again thank you uh
thank dr costrava for his time today and
his important research
we would also like to thank labyrinth
and our sponsor brooker daltonix for
underwriting today's educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
please join us next week for part two of
our webinar series
fluorotype technology as reliable
diagnostic tool
during covet 19 and flu season
that's all for now thank you so much for
joining us and until next time
bye bye everyone